in Berlin im Stadtteil Spandau liegt
seit Jahren dieses Boot dicht am Ufer
der hafel Anwohner Spaziergänger und
Kapitäne haben immer wieder auf das
abgesoffene Segelboot hingewiesen aber
nichts passiert der Eigentümer unbekannt
verzogen und keine Behörde fühlt sich
dafür zuständig viel mehr wird die
Verantwortung fleißig hin und her
geschoben hab auch ein Boot und fahre da
immer vorbei und wunder mich dass nicht
mal irgendjemand rausnimmt ja ich meine
wenn sie ihr Autos auf der Straße oder
Müll auf der Straße haben wirürdet ja
auch weggeräumt ne ich bin ein bisschen
fassungslos weil es geht ja hier viel um
Natur und Umwelt und das wird eigentlich
heutzutage sehr groß geschrieben seit
Anfang 2019 liegt das Segelboot am Rand
der hafel der Mast ist inzwischen
verschwunden dafür hat es aber einen
Spitznamen bekommen Yellow Submarine
schrottboote sind in Berlin keine
Seltenheit sie liegen an Stegen oder
eben einfach irgendwo im Wasser und
gammeln vor sich hin häufig sind die
Eigentümer nicht mehr zu
ermitteln bei der Yellow Submarine geht
es seit Jahren um die Frage ist das Boot
ein Wrack und damit eine Gefahr für die
Schiffahrt dann wäre das
Bundeswasserstraßen und schiffahrtsamt
zuständig wenn das Boot aber nur
fahruntüchtig im Uferbereich ankert
wären das Land Berlin oder der
Stadtbezirk verantwortlich die teure
Entsorgung des problembootes will
niemand übernehmen also das wo es ist
wir haben eh das Thema Wasserqualität
hier an der an der hafel mit mit viel zu
viel Dünger im im Wasser oder
Nährstoffen wenn jetzt noch Motorenöl
von irgendwelchen Schiffen dazu kommt
oder von irgendwelchen Fracks wäre das
fatal sowohl das Bezirksamt Spandau als
auch die Berliner Senatsverwaltung für
Verkehr weisen jede Zuständigkeit von
sich schriftlich heißt es das Boot liegt
im Bereich der unteren
hafelwasserstraße
Bundeswasserstraße für
Bundeswasserstraßen in Berlin ist das
Wasserstraßen und schiffahrtsamt
sprehafel
zuständig doch das Wasserstraßen und
schiffahrtsamt sprehafel sieht sich
genauso wenig in der Pflicht es schreibt
uns das Schiff sei nicht gesunken
sondern liegt vor Anker eine Gefahr für
die Schiffahrt besteht zurzeit nicht von
dem schier endlosen Behörden Pingpong
sind viele nur noch genervt ich kann das
nicht nachvollziehen dass da ein
schrottboot über vier Jahre lang
herumliegt und niemand sich darum
kümmert dass abzutransportieren völlig
unverständlich dass da nicht irgendeine
Behörde für zuständig ist und sagt das
ist Müllentsorgung illegale die schaffen
wir jetzt hier mal weg hoffentlich säuft
die Yellow Submarine nicht auch noch
komplett ab wer weiß welche Behörde dann
für das U-Boot zuständig wäre